let's get uh we'll get back on track now
we have the story from fox news
gavin newsom savagely mocked as
disgusting transphobe for claiming men
can't get pregnant at abortion rally
quote if men could get pregnant this
wouldn't even be a conversation the
governor told the crowd of abortion
supporters you know what is missing from
this headline though he was mocked by
conservatives in jest as a transphobe
because the left doesn't care that he
said this but gavin newsom said that if
men could get pregnant this would be a
conversation i was told back in 2016 by
the daily beast that men were getting
pregnant you have that story about the
pregnant man what's he talking about
wait so the left is not mocking him at
all that's surprising because they
usually eat their own i mean i am not
surprised that conservatives are ripping
on him but the left's usually pretty
good they don't care they don't care we
saw how fast they were able to define
what a woman was when rowe leaked when
the decision leaked they're like all of
a sudden we know what it is don't make
laws about women's bodies this is why i
don't get sarcastic as a rebuttal to
someone i don't agree with because
they'll take you out of context and make
you sound like an ill i yeah agree with
the argument that men should not be
passing laws on women's bodies oh i
completely agree and that means that the
supreme court 1973 that was all male
should not have been shrined roe v wade
right that's right but they passed the
law saying you can't pass a law they
what they said they passed a law saying
you can't pass a law
they told the states you can't they
passed a law that or they made a supreme
court decision that states can't pass
laws yeah that's the first amendment
yeah the first amendment says they said
we're choosing to decide that they can't
choose whether or not to decide if you
can choose that's literally what the
constitution does okay like it restricts
the government from doing certain things
this is funny when everybody got mad
about the parental rights and education
bill like junk yogurt the young turks
he's just oh man he's always so useless
but he was like you're opposing free
speech and it's like yo the government
can restrict itself
like imagine if ian declared i will no
longer be allowed to talk about freeing
the code they'd be like you're violating
your free speech like no he's choosing
not to talk also i'm curious if jank
thinks that not being able to teach
creationism in schools is a violation of
religious freedom
it's a violation of free speech
teachers should be allowed to discuss
creationism with kids in secret that's
right and say don't tell your parents
what we taught you here today all right
and the math problems are like what was
the one jesus rose
no one needs to get the animals on is
ours there's two animals in each species
there's this many species how many
animals do we have to create some nuance
on the government restricting itself
you've got the federal government
restricting the state government and
those are not the same governments you
might argue that they're not restricting
them though i mean they're giving them
they're giving them the freedom no no no
like the first amendment at the federal
level protects us against state
repression as well
but there was a that was a court case
someone was mentioning this on the show
that it didn't used to be that way that
the federal government's cons only
referred to itself and the states refer
to themselves but at some point the
federal government superseded all of the
states it had to do with the farmer
revolt like 1783 i think if i'm not sure
those those years are right but anyways
later well yeah also on this point of it
being a restriction of free expression
to not tell you know to not allow
teachers to spread their perverse sexual
practices for students i mean like okay
even if that was the case then fine
teachers shouldn't be expressing their
you know perverted sexuality students
but it's not as if there is such a thing
as a right a to have secret
conversations with other people's
children but b
to be part of an institution that the
parents are funding with their tax money
and not give the parents a say in what
their children are being taught there's
no such right actually shamus it's the
uh 31st amendment that uh teachers shall
have the right to have secret
conversations with children about sex
and tell the children not to tell their
parents see this is why i gotta study
civics more man this is oh that that's
the constitution in 20 years
i'm sorry i'm sorry if you want to talk
about sex with my child do not pass go
do not collect two hundred dollars
straight to jail yeah
yeah
will you home school are you our will
you home school i don't know he's peeing
on me right now i haven't really gone
that far
you have to be like excuse me sir please
don't pee on me please stop no you know
what he does
you know he does he laughs and then he
paints that's great because he likes my
reaction i scream every time so he
laughs and then he pees oh good for him
someone else laughed until they peed
last night who was that gosh what was a
dream i had i don't know maybe it was a
dream you had a dream he laughed until
you know it wasn't me no i was watching
scare videos on youtube and some girl
was like
and looked down to see if she peed
herself oh my gosh what kind of stuff
are you watching oh so many things
we're talking about oh yeah gavin newsom
changed his political position for
convenience oh yes yeah so i said tip if
they say no uterus no opinion just
remind them that trans women are women
and somebody said sarcasm further
entrenches differing opinions you're
literally doing their work for them by
furthering further adding credibility to
the premise even if you're trying to be
funny i'm not trying to be funny at all
i'm trying to illuminate to them the
duplicity of their own arguments they
don't they don't like using them they
don't they don't they don't care i i
tweeted uh pregnant men have no say in
abortion because they are men i don't
care if they don't care i care if the
people watching care well yeah but the
people who already agree with us i guess
you know what we're looking for is
people who aren't paying attention
moderates yes you know to see the people
who aren't paying attention they're not
necessarily moderates they're also
liberals who aren't paying attention
they don't know what's going on but i
tweeted pregnant men have no say in
abortion because they are men and i
really do feel like it's a it's a
perfect tweet because it's uh it's it's
you you literally can't argue anything
about it because it's like they're both
left-wing positions but they both
contradict they both contradict so it's
like which of your positions are you mad
about yeah so it's like tell me i'm
wrong but which of your positions are
are you mad about that men can't have a
say on this or that pregnant men do have
a say in this i'm i don't even care
anymore i'm just so tired of the not
common sense like men are not women i
don't care i don't even need to make fun
of your argument like common sense is
common sense that's what men are not
women and i'm so tired of living in this
clown world it's a clown world at this
point yeah men are not really able to
get pregnant right no no okay no okay
good not at all not sure what so here's
let's let's break it down here's what
happens um blaire white is always the
go-to example conservative trans woman
but i bring up blair because ben shapiro
said
in writing
he would use he him pronouns for blair
because blair is male
but in public it's it's too complicated
to explain to a person that blair is
male so if he was like someone said
where should i sit oh go sit by her
because he can't if he says him people
would be like where i don't see him you
say blair
but if the person didn't know who blair
was
and so what happens then is
we recognize that
you know someone who is like a trans man
or a trans woman
for
ease of of conversation people might be
like oh her she etc but then it
translates into a legal realm where a
younger generation who's growing up with
it says then they are women
if you accept this so it starts with
tolerance of being like
okay for the ease and purpose of
communication we'll just say we get it
but then young people are like that's a
woman
and so now you have
men can get pregnant
when man is defined as adult human male
adult human males can't get pregnant so
i tweeted
trans women are not adult human females
because they're literally not according
to every
dictionary to wikipedia to every
encyclopedia to every understanding and
i got two reactions one was
congratulations tim you idiot you just
discovered the difference between sex
and gender
the others were
you're a bigot that's not true why would
you say this and like now we're going to
come after you and i'm like i didn't say
anything to anybody i didn't target
anybody i didn't insult anybody i made a
fact statement based on wikipedia that's
all it was
yeah well also oh you discovered the
difference between sex and gender
actually there is no such distinction it
was invented by a pervert and pedophile
named dr john money yes he was a weirdo
he was an actual he was a very what was
in he had studies about um like
seven-year-olds that's kinsey no well
well money also did so yeah dr john
money had a a an infant boy given a sex
change at a young age because he
underwent a botched circumcision and
then had the parents raised him as a
girl and and then
killed themselves yeah he forced him and
his bro he forced him to live as a girl
and he forced him and his brother into
doing like depraved acts on camera adult
activity yes yeah on camera and filmed
it disgusting perfect he coined the
terms gender identity sexual orientation
he got the dsm to adopt the term
pedophilia instead of deviance they both
killed themselves
this is the double-edged sword of tv
radio internet is that we see this crazy
stuff now because people have probably
been doing this for millennia chopping
people apart and doing but now they
weren't
celebrated exactly no there was it was
you saw how gross it was at the time and
but the double edge of that is that the
mind virus can spread like if people
think they're frogs and people don't
feel accepted and they want to be part
of a group they go to become part of the
i'm a frog group
especially for children too and it's
really confusing to tell them it's
interchangeable at any time you want i
mean if you tell a kid they're a rabbit
they're going to hop around and ask for
carrots that's just how kids are and you
have i'm in new york city you know you
have nine-year-olds there that are
saying they're transgender and they are
presenting as you know a little girl
presenting as a boy and their their
parents are okay with it and it's like a
status symbol there it's like oh i'm so
loving and accepting and they're putting
it on these kids like this
they have no idea what they're doing
there's a libs of tick tock video that
just went up where the mother is doing a
grammar lesson with her child her son
and it's a bunch of sentences juan
went on the swing
sarah rode her bike or sarah you know
yeah like got on you know on her bike or
whatever and it's like which pronoun
would you use and he put they for all of
them and the mom was like why did you do
that and he's like because we don't know
what gender they are and she goes but
look at their names and he goes you said
nothing is a boy or a girl and she was
like but you their names and then she
went uh well i guess i have to give you
an a because i did say it it's like
she's confused that when she tells a
little boy these names are not boy or
girl so he goes i guess i'll use they
because he doesn't know the difference
between a male and a female name i mean
the ideological underpinnings of the
left that have been forced on this
country have actually mandated adults to
become dumber than children is the moral
of that story because they want to throw
out
rationalization and reasoning they don't
want you to think my fear is that it
hasn't even been forced on people that
they've acquiesced to they've chosen it
because they feel so dissolved over the
future
no i think kids are pressured they're
your kids are forced into the adults
however you disenfranchise they have no
hope so they they they revert to no no
that's that's that's that's you're
missing the the big picture here
we used to grow up in the real world we
used to have animals we used to watch
animals we used to watch each other we
used to be on farms we used to work hard
we used to recognize that if you didn't
wake up at 6 a.m and tell the field you
didn't eat now we have everything we
have good times making soft people they
don't they don't see livestock they
don't know how animals work they don't
know where their food comes from so
they're growing up completely detached
from reality
that's what's happening that parent
who's like why is my son doing these
things it's because she grew up in a
bubble world with no requirements so
it's just this confused state of
i should have things for free
nothing is real blank slate all of that
stuff
you look at people who grew up in rural
areas and they're like better farm or
that's it no food yeah we had a way
a couple weeks ago that said that they
never even had to do i think it was um
oh gosh it was uh
the cowboy the the um philosophia
braxton mccoy philosophical cowboy
someone called him or something like
that uh he said that he never really had
to have sex ed talks with his kids
because they grew up on a farm so they
already know chickens check this out you
didn't even need to give the chicken sex
out we have chicken city they just know
we have chicken city out of the basement
and i can't remember who it was the
other day said oh a fight's breaking out
and the chickens were doing it and i was
like
bro the the male the
jumped on the back of the female and
then started thrusting and you thought
it was a fight another thing that
happens i had someone say to me
so why would you want to have roosters
do they like do they lay different kinds
of eggs
no they do yeah and i was like roosters
are deported deport them immediately
i don't blame people i blame civil i
blame our society
but it's like it's it's a natural
process we've come to the point where we
are so pampered where we have we have
factory farms i know a lot of people
dispute the idea but listen i'm talking
about
the pink slime that is chicken nuggets
you used to have to go and you raise the
chickens and you're throwing you know
grains or whatever or you're turning
over the wood for the bugs and then
eventually you're like time to eat this
chicken time to eat these eggs you know
what was really crazy to me and i mean
crazed experience growing up in a city
the first time i ate my own my own
chicken's egg i was like do i have to do
anything to it do i have to clean it
can i sterilize it should i put my hand
sanitizer over it tim got the dish soap
and a sponge out he was scrubbing that
thing already the only reason i haven't
been eating them is because i'm afraid
they're fertilized they are all
fertilized does it matter no it does get
a little half grown chicken fetus in
there when you crack it no it's like a
little white dot which is the chicken
fetus basically it's well it's the spunk
from the rooster um is it okay to eat
yes yeah that's that's that's the crazy
thing
throughout human history we've had since
uh the chickens were like what 100 a.d
that question was not asked is it better
for you to have a fertilizer no no like
imagine being a kid growing up in the
year 200 a.d actually did you guys see
the northmen
they mentioned you know something about
like being a slave like because they
were like nordic slaves and he's like
you'll go out working with the silkies
silkies are kind of chicken they've been
here for a long time they're so fuzzy
yeah they're fluffy and they they're
funny and they're goofy they make funny
sounds
sit listen listen
people would walk into the forest and
grab chives right off the ground and go
food and they would walk back and put it
down they go hey and then i'll just eat
it it's like that's food you can't do
that i get i get anxiety going to the
grocery store because i'm like what's in
this i'm like is this a what is this
real chicken is this you know pumped
full of saline what's in it probably is
it's it's we're better off with cleaner
foods but to a limit right like that i
watched some documentary about how they
mixed like beef with ammonia to like get
rid of the like the the bacteria from it
and then mix it back into other meat
well even the chickens we have now are
like mutants they're mutant chickens
that we have no they're nothing like i
mean the the difference between chickens
now and a hundred years ago they're
flavorless they're giant they're they're
mutants exactly good times create soft
chickens that's right
um
good times mutant chickens mutant
chickens create hard times
hard times create normal but so here's
my here's my point here's my point
we i i remember it was uh like 2014 i
got first chickens ever they laid eggs
and then i was like okay i've never done
this before and i'm how old was i like
then this was this is
what is this uh eight years ago so i'm
like 26 27 and i'm like i have never
eaten an egg from a chicken before what
do i do
and i'm looking up online do i do i have
to wash it do i have to like cook it to
a certain temperature and it was like it
basically said if you keep your chicken
safe and healthy you can eat a raw and i
was like what no you could sell manila
it's like no that's because of modern
you know poultry conditions and stuff
and i was like really so timmy's like
i'm going rocky crack that egg put in a
cup threw it yeah do you eat them raw at
all
no i use them to make um i've been
making like a nut bread it's amazing you
just mix some nut powder like walnut
powder and some almond flour with the
egg and then you microwave it you get a
little bun and then i put cheese and
egg and bananas i do
so you make it like you cut out a little
circle in the middle and then you crack
the egg and you can dip it in it and
make it nice and runny but the other
thing too is uh we have chives in the
yard all over the place
because chives grow early season and i
just went out we grabbed a whole bunch
and chopped them up and threw it in our
beef it was so good we have wine berries
we got more flavor than anything you buy
at the store too yeah refrigerator can
destroy the flavor especially with
tomatoes wine berries you see these they
got appalachia all over the place
they're little chinese raspberries that
are everywhere
during wineberry season you walk outside
and you get like two pounds in like 20
minutes you just shuffle them into bowls
but people who live in cities don't know
anything about this so they're just
they are they are like children so that
you know i'm not trying to be overly
disrespectful i am saying quite
literally
200 300 years ago people had to mature
they had to survive hardship today it's
so good that these people are confused
about whether or not they can eat an egg
yeah no and the food we are getting is
just so bad i think you can fact check
me out i think you have to eat like
eight peaches now to get the same
nutritional value as a peach like 50
years ago yeah everything even fruit
veggies
i don't know what it is that would be uh
they were probably yeah i bet people
would now the egg shells back in the day
you know yeah probably i bet people
would eat orange rind they'd be like
don't waste it of course you know what
that's good is putting the eggshells in
your bathtub when you're taking a bath
and soaking in that water i bet that's
really good for your skin just just
thought came to me yeah i was thinking
about skin tougher my eyes was so good i
had a friend right through porous i had
a friend in arizona who lived by what
she called a citrus tree and it was
because she was like all the different
citrus like cross breeds or whatever
kind of hoes weird fruit but i'm looking
at the trees it's true i'm looking at
this tree and it's just got like
500
oranges or whatever in it and then i'm
like man imagine being some just you
know like nomadic tribal person and
you're looking for food and you come
across this one tree with all of these
fruits and you're like
and you just take it all and you're like
look what i found and everyone's like oh
food because like food's hard to come by
and they're like eating it like crazy
and they're just eating whatever they
can get yeah and not just food oh sorry
liz you go no not yeah yeah no you don't
all right
i was just gonna say you can get these
citrus like fruits that have like horns
like a devil because they're so weird
and kind of incestuous they like mix
with all different kinds of citrus you
can get like grapefruit crossbreeds with
lemons crossbreeds with limes you get
these weird funky things that are really
good they're great for humans but anyway
sheamus yeah no i was just gonna say if
you came across that it's not just that
you found food it's that you found a
very rare and very sweet and very
delicious food nowadays we've sort of
been spoiled by these foods that have
very intense flavors that would not
occur naturally in nature right well
that was redundant but you'll come
across like
historically if someone found an orange
or a strawberry or an apple i mean that
was really a treat for them like this is
delicious and nowadays people like fruit
gross i want a kitkat yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there